Let's talk about how we got that tricky
last answer.
For composite functions, the domain of f
composed with g is all the x values in
the domain of g that lead to g of x
values that are in the domain of f.
Well, what on earth does that mean?
That's definitely a mouthful.
But basically it means that in order for
a number to be in the domain of this
composite function, it must be in the
domain of the inner function g in this
case, and in the domain of the composite
function itself.
If we have f of x equals one over x
squared and g of x equals the square root
of x, then what is f composed with g.
And what is the domain of that composite function.
Please write this in inequality notation.